c'est pas ça qui va empêcher les
accidents c'est pas la vitesse
m'étonnerait ça m'étonnerait que laura
moye d'accès dans la digue km ça
m'étonnerait j'y trouve à 80 kilomètres
on peut avoir des accidents mortels mais
bon auprès des particuliers l'annoncent
ne fait pas l'unanimité le gouvernement
a annoncé mardi 9 janvier la baisse de
la limitation de 90 à 80 km heure sur
les routes secondaires sans séparateur
central
les professionnels de la route on peut
aussi appris la nouvelle
pour ce chauffeur de taxi il faut
surtout changer les mentalités
le taux d'accidentologie pour moi je
trouve que il a augmenté suite au
comportement des gens sur la route
donc nous en tant que professionnels de
la route on s'en rend bien compte bien
sur la souris suffit que vous êtes sur
une voie vous êtes peut-être sa conduite
et mettra en dessous de la vitesse
maximale la personne derrière de lessive
est en retard à sa réunion constat
partagé par ce coursier qui travaille
sur les routes depuis 21 ans
pour lui le problème est avant tout
comportementale moi ce qui me fait peur
et ce que je remarque depuis un ou deux
ans et
c'est le téléphone portable je trouve
que c'est un véritable danger
je pense qu'une personne consciente qui
roulent à 90 en étant bien concentré sur
la route
je pense qu'elle est moins dangereuse
qu'une personne qui roule à 80 équitable
des textos mais plus que le téléphone
l'alcool serait la première cause de
mortalité routière suivi par les excès
de vitesse depuis trois ans le nombre de
tués augmente en 2016 plus de 3400
personnes ont perdu la vie sur les
routes